Resuelve para "x", tenemos a 8 que multiplica
a "3x" más 10 es igual a "28x" menos 14 menos "4x".
Como hemos hecho en todas las ecuaciones hasta
ahora, queremos agrupar las "x" de un solo lado,
pero antes de hacer eso, vamos a
simplificar ambos lados.
Del lado izquierdo vamos a multiplicar "3x"
más 10 por 8, así es que básicamente vamos
a distribuir el 8, vamos a aplicar la propiedad
distributiva aquí, esto nos queda 8 por "3x" = "24x"
más 8 por 10 = 80 que es igual a...
y del lado derecho tenemos "28x" menos 14 menos "4x",
vamos a combinar "28x" y "-4x",
esto es igual a "28x" menos "4x" = "24x" menos 14.
Y lo siguiente que hacemos...
pero espera, esta ecuación ya es un tanto sospechosa,
vamos a confirmar esto restando
"24x" a ambos lados de la ecuación,
si hacemos eso van a desaparecer las "x" pues aquí tenemos "24x" del lado izquierdo y "24x"
del lado derecho, al pasar estas "24x" del
otro lado se eliminan.
Veámoslo.
Restamos "24x" del lado derecho y
"24x" del lado izquierdo,
¿qué nos queda?
del lado izquierdo estos términos se cancelan
y nos queda 80 es igual, del lado derecho,
estos dos términos se cancelan y nos queda
tan solo -14.
Y esto es realmente bizarro, pues la ecuación
ahora estipula que 80 es igual a -14,
pero sabemos que eso no es verdad, eso no sucede,
80 no es igual a -14, 80 es distinto de -14,
así es que esta ecuación en realidad no
tiene solución.
Esto no tiene solución...
no tiene solución.
no hay valor de "x" que haga 80 igual a -14.